hey meta look and tell me what you
see I see a person wearing a black
hoodie and jeans standing in front of a
large window with a camera held up to
their eye so these are the meta Rayband
smart glasses I did a video about them
already earlier this year but they just
got an update that I have early access
to that makes this smart assistant
multimodal so it connects the AI to the
camera on the front and it's pretty good
so you always have to start it with the
same phrase so I have to say hey meta
look and tell me how to save this plant
the plant appears to be a draa which is
known for its durability and low
maintenance requirements to save it make
sure it's getting enough and direct
sunlight and water it sparingly allowing
the soil to dry out between waterings so
it's pretty basic now but theoretically
in the future you can look at a leaky
faucet and it can tell you how to fix it
or you can look at a restaurant menu
it'll read the whole thing and tell you
which ones have nuts or which ones are
spicy accessibility aside that's pretty
cool